quoi on pouvait
non mais
la jacquerie je vous ai découvert dans
le film les amours imaginaires
2009le xavier dolan par la suite j'ai eu
la rance et nourrissent
c'est vrai que c'est une belle période
pour vous parlerez important ça
représente pour moi c'est comme si je
sortais de l'eau en fait j'avais
l'impression que avant de rencontrer
xavier j'étais sous l'eau que je savais
pas c'est comme si j'ai rencontré ma
famille on va tous vous aviez ma famille
artistique jantes en effet toute carte
de visite en quelque sorte
bon ok complètement non seulement les
amours imaginaires faut savoir pis en
m'excusant la défection d'un film en
france particulièrement c'est vraiment
le film culte là c'est vraiment c'est de
l'or de ferris bueller df loti c'est
comme les jeunes entrent chez pas même
ceux qui sont plus jeunes aujourd'hui
mais entre 16 et 30 ans ils ont vu les
amours imaginaires c'est vraiment ils
disent les répliques sont
l'idée s'est constamment vous avez du
monde sans voix qui sur instagram et des
gens qui font des dessins des amours
imaginaires de nos personnages 35 ans et
la date de péremption pour une actrice
vous jouez dans une toute nouvelle
comédie intitulée ima peeters
vous incarnez une jeune femme de 35 ans
en fait votre âge dans la vraie vie et a
dit qu'il y ait une date de péremption
pour une comédienne qu'après 35 ans et
plus difficile dans le métier
est ce que c'est votre a lui aussi chuté
mais on sait jamais quand il joue et
quand je vois surtout c'est vrai que si
on n'a pas comme acteur
disons à moins d'exceptions là si on n'a
pas comme acteur eu des rôles des jeunes
dans la vingtaine ont commencé à voir
des rôles
vers la mi trentaine quarantaine c'est
assez complexe parce que souvent ce que
ce que vont faire les cinéastes et
prendre des acteurs déjà confirmés
donc c'est ce que c'est ce que raconte
emma petter en fait c'est qu'elle sent
qu'elle est au moment où de toute façon
on va devoir abandonner cette carrière
là j'ai décidé d'en finir en finir avec
cours j'ai gâché les dix dernières
années de ma vie alors voilà j'arrête
tu veux plus faire actrice je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
il ya effectivement l'espèce de creux
peut-être les actrices vers 55 1 jusqu'à
nous voulons l deviennent des grands
mères c'est comme s'ils avaient une
période que parent and my friend je
dirais tu n'as fait le jeu dur un très
gros mot à la télévision mais se dit en
football c'est à dire c'est le moment où
le désir n'est plus palpable chez la
crise on n'a plus de désir
c'est sur cette femme parce qu'elles ne
représentent plus la fertilité
ce sera l'enjeu on fait des actrices et
c'est le rapport bur donc je pense que
le grand défi aujourd'hui j'espère si
moi j'ai une fille je vais je l'élever
comme ça j'espère que les petites filles
seront élevés comme ça que c'est pas
grave de déplaire c'est pas grave
puis on n'est pas obligé on n'est pas le
nez sur cette terre pour plaire on est
là pour que je pense que les hommes ont
vraiment moins de problème avec ça moi
j'ai beaucoup plus d'amis un qui me
dérange pas ce que les autres pensent de
moi beaucoup moins finir vous semblez
vouloir prendre le chemin de la
réalisation 2019 sera une grosse année
pour vous l'année de la sortie de votre
premier long métrage de la femme de mon
frère
un brin nerveuse quand quand vous sentez
par rapport à tous les sens à la fois
excessivement fébriles à l'idée que les
jasées ça fait cinq ans que moi je porte
le projet donc ça c est long le vivre
avec
avec ça avec ses névroses mais et je
suis très fébrile puis en même temps
j'ai
j'ai peur de la réaction des gens
explications je le connais personne dans
notre métier qui pond un peu tourmenté
ou qui apporte une forme d'anxiété
je pense que ça vient un peu avec notre
notre métier après ça je pense que que
les rôles peuvent servir de
de catalyseur à une certaine anxiété
même si je suis une grande fan de freud
il disait quand même des choses pires
pays en haleine c'était sur la
créativité qui dit que les les artistes
qu'ils arrêtaient de créer pouvait
sombrer dans des formes de pression mais
je pense sincèrement que ça nul que ça
peut sauver les artistes de deux
certaine mélancolie
voilà chaque rue je vous souhaite de la
créativité ce merci beaucoup merci